also here tonight uh florida senator
marco rubio thank you for joining me
senator i i'm very concerned about these
developments regarding the doj
potentially cracking down on what
obviously ought to be something that
parents are able to voice in terms of
their critiques of what is being taught
to their uh to their children within
these public schools and to the policies
of the schools
what is your reaction to this news
regarding the eoj well first of all it's
alarming and second of all it's
hypocritical it's alarming because this
idea that somehow you know if parents
show up at a school board to complain
if somebody there decides well we don't
like his tone of voice we don't like how
loud he's speaking we don't like how
often he shows up
you can be reported the federal bureau
of investigation which should be focused
on things like organized crime things
like drug traffickers things like
terrorism and others who seek to harm
this country is now going to divert
resources to investigate parents because
they scream too loudly or maybe are even
rude at a school board hearing and
hypocritical because let me tell you
there is very few of any senators
certainly people on the right members of
congress as well who have not been
harassed in their private life now
obviously you just interviewed senator
paul and he's gone through some pretty
extreme situations but i personally had
people show up at my home when i'm there
when i'm not there they don't respect it
it's your home i have people there
confront my family at my home we don't
make videos out of it but they sometimes
do i don't see a lot of concern i was
here a couple years ago when the supreme
court hearings were going on there were
senators being chased into elevators and
down the hall and the way it was covered
by a lot of people on the presses
you get what you deserve you deserve to
be run out and in fact you had maxine
waters and others on television
basically saying if you see these people
on public screen adam not just be nasty
and rude to them try to intimidate them
so they have normalized this behavior
when it comes to left-wing protesters
but then when a parent speaks out about
a school board they want to sick the fbi
on them this is crazy like if you had
told me five years ago this was going to
happen i said there's just no way
there's no way something like this would
happen it's happening
senator before i i have another question
for you on a different topic but
i am very concerned that one of the
results of this is going to be
there's going to have to be security
details for every u.s senator at the end
of the day we've we've always prided
ourselves on the ability of of citizens
to be able to approach the senator and
to have access to them to talk to them
over the years
are those days going to be in the past
for us
i don't think having a security detail
for a member of congress is possible i
don't think you could do that you
couldn't afford you couldn't hire enough
people to do it i don't know that
wouldn't be practical i think the what
is going to happen here is something
terrible is going to happen eventually
because we have basically normalized
this behavior and understand it's
hypocritical because the left says if
you're doing it to someone on the right
they deserve it if you're doing it to
someone on the left or someone who comes
from their agenda you should be
investigated i never thought i would
live to see the day that this kind of
thing would be happening in this country
i know that you're very concerned about
what's going on at the border that we've
been covering here at fox over the past
weeks and months
what is your take in terms of any kind
of approach that can be done to actually
make the biden administration respond to
this particularly supposed border czar
kamala harris well kama harris shouldn't
be the borders though she's not doing
anything and if she's the one that's
actually running this then they need to
find somebody else and that's what i've
asked them to do second it begins with
accepting the reality okay just a lot
just haitian migrants alone there's
between 90 and 120 000
haitian migrants some of them have been
living in chile or ecuador for the
better part of 10 years who now those
countries ran out of jobs and so now
they're looking to make the journey
north they are at various stages of
transit and we are being told that by
country after country in the region not
just from haiti alone not not to mention
the other places and if you talk to
people at the border or people that have
crossed they will all tell you the same
thing they expect to get into the united
states they expect to enter they expect
to be released a pending an asylum
hearing that many have no intention to
show up for and when they make the
journey they call back home they let
other people know about it and it
encourages more people to do the same
this is a rolling catastrophe we're
going to continue to see incidents like
what we saw just two weeks ago and my
heart breaks for people from haiti and
all over the world but no nation on
earth can have the open border we
basically have now and just tell anyone
who wants to come please show up you
can't do it but that's what this
administration thinks they're going to
do and if kamala harris is the one in
charge of this they need to find
somebody else and fast
senator rubio thanks so much for joining
me tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else